it's up there on the top of the shelf
over there left-hand side that's the
first computer I built yes no no that
tighly home designed including anodizing
the aluminium in the kitchen sink in
things like that is my introduction to
computing was through my work in the
engineering department at Cambridge I
was fascinated by aeroplanes and
aerodynamics and I moved from my first
degree in maths to a PhD in rather
theoretical aerodynamics in the course
of that PhD I was using some machines to
control the experiments and such like so
I wasn't entirely theoretical and but at
that time also a bunch of enthusiasts
formed the Cambridge University
processor group I wasn't a founder but I
did go to the first meeting and got to
know the founders and thought well this
is interesting I'm interested in
pursuing my my love of flying by
building a flight simulator so how do I
go about doing that in the late 1970s
which is when I started tinkering with
computers flight simulators were very
large expensive professional machines at
the time and so I didn't really have a
clear path from starting to build a
microprocessor to to building my own
flight simulator that was a big stretch
but you've clearly defied if I was going
to pursue this that that this was the
right place to start and I started at
the beginning buying a microprocessor
and some other chips and assembling a
very simple computer and and gradually
my I I forgot about the flight simulator
bit and and got more interested in the
computing bit of course the the flight
simulator interest came full circle when
when I discovered aviator on the BBC
micro several years later I mean that
was a spectacular Flight Simulator
considering the capabilities of the
resources it had on the BBC micro so
that kind of completed the circle for me
that in the meantime I'd take the
tangent into computing and
stayed permanently on it hobbyist
computer clubs were definitely becoming
popular in the west coast in California
and just a beginning to start in the UK
but we were following behind the
Americans at that point but it was very
much the similar theme
probably being a student group it was a
similar thing with far smaller resources
but yes he was just enthusiasts building
stuff comparing notes it was it was
really the point in history where it
became possible for somebody sitting at
home with a little bit of money and a
soldering iron to assemble a computer
that was pretty basic that's still
useful and entertaining and the machines
I was using in my PhD where the things
like the computer automation lsi 4 and
they were not enormous ly more powerful
than the sort of things you could build
for you know 100 pounds at home people
picked up the techniques for building
computers from clubs talking to other
people who are ahead of them but also I
think pretty much from magazines there
were a number of magazines around at the
time with titles such as wireless world
which is a long-standing one electronics
today international I remember was one
of my favorites practical electronics
maybe that was American I'm not quite
sure but these magazines not only had
articles on how you could go about
building stuff but of course they also
had adverts from the shops that would
sell you stuff I remember being very
nervous
buying the parts for my first machine I
bought the parts mail-order from
California and that meant using a credit
card over the telephone internationally
and as a student I'd never done that
before well it worked out fine the chips
arrived you know they took two or three
weeks to arrive through the post that
that's how we found the components the
chips were made by the big names of the
time Texas Instruments Motorola was
around then the microprocessor I used
was designed and manufactured by
significant even then were owned by
Philips we picked up ideas from the
meetings of the processor group but
there
basically we went off and bought bits
and and and tried to assemble them the
the processor group also had meetings in
each other's houses and I remember the
group of people meeting in my house in
Cambridge which was seventh and John's
Road at the time and and somebody called
Roger Wilson that I got to know a little
bit through the process a group poking
around in my machine and finding a bug
in the memory and that was the first
time what you found a bug in my hardware
it was definitely not the last time at
the time we started building machines
memory chips were available so they were
very small I think my first machine used
one kilobit static Rams so a thousand
bits of memory on the chip but the whole
machine was integrated circuits so we
were not dealing very much with with
transistors at all I remember I did have
to deal with transistors because I built
a card for programming eeproms and
eproms
required at that time minus 5 + 5 + + 12
volts and you had to switch a
programming pin at quite a high voltage
so that particular circuit board has
quite a few discrete transistors on but
I wasn't an electronics engineer I
didn't get on very well with transistors
I preferred the the chips even in the
analog domain I know my introduction to
electronics was was in the analog domain
using 741 op amps to build sound systems
I built 8-track sound mixers and so on
I could understand chips I did a lot of
my own soldering yes and and the
computer stuff was all built with Vera
wah which was a fairly standard
technology at the time it involved sold
reek but you had a wiring pen and a
standard printed circuit board that was
a generic and you put the sockets in and
then with this wiring pin you would
basically wrap it round one of the
socket legs take you around a few combs
and then wrap it around the other end
this was very fine wire with I think of
some kind of polyurethane insulation I
think and when you soldered it the
in melted but where the wire was not
sold and it was insulated so you could
run lots of wires down these combs and
they wouldn't short-circuit
I learned sometime later that the the
fumes given off by soldering this wire
we're not very pleasant but this was not
advertised at the time what I recall and
this is a long time ago and I'm not
known for my memory and if you talk to
to Sophie Wilson memory of this era is
much better than mine but I seem to
recall I was in my office at the
engineering department and and the phone
rang there was no email then and it was
Herman and and Herman said he'd like to
come and talk to me I think he came to
my office in the engineering department
sat down there and said that he and
Chris Currie were thinking of starting a
company and they were looking for a few
people to help them on the technical
side they obviously looked at the
processor group because that was the
area they were looking at was i
interested and I'm fairly sure my reply
was along the lines of well this is a
fairly recently acquired hobby as far as
I'm concerned I can't claim any
expertise but you know if you think I
can help then then I'm happy to have a
go and that that's where it started the
next meeting I remember was a meeting
with Herman Chris and Chris Turner at
the force and George on midsummer common
in Cambridge and we sat in this pub the
four of us and the plans were firming up
a bit I don't remember if at that time
they'd begun to talk about the fruit
machine contract which was the first
piece of development contractual work
they got the fruit machine contract was
about converting fruit machines from
electromechanical which is how they all
worked up to that point to
microprocessor controlled which was the
way it was all going in there's stayed
ever since so we were taking
machine which is a one-armed bandit you
know the thing you never put money into
but I'm very averse to all forms of
gambling and I understand why the state
has to license and tax it I still don't
understand why they sponsor it through
national lotteries I think this is very
bad idea but that's just my principles
which is slightly clash with working on
the fruit machine project I wasn't
entirely comfortable that it was a
technical challenge and that seemed to
override my principles at the time yes
so we basically took the old
electromechanical controller out and
then replaced it with it for me to be
complicated microprocessor control
system which involved two national
semiconductor SCMP micro processors
running in parallel getting that to work
and passing some of the robustness tests
was quite instructive so as soon as we
said we had a working system the first
thing they wanted us to do was plug it
into a main socket with one of those
block adapters plug a small arc welding
kit into the other socket and then weld
metal while using the flute machine to
see how this this was what passed does
EMC testing in those days I think and
the other problem they knew about was
that there were some electronic fruit
machines already out on the market and
users had discovered that they were very
prone to paying out if you used an
electronic cigarette lighter close to
the cache socket the electronic
cigarette lighters were just too great
the source of interference it just
injects a jolt and if you did this
enough times it would throw cash at you
so one thing that that Roger did very
early on was built an FM radio receiver
which detected anybody trying to do this
and immediately made sure whatever the
Machine did it didn't pay out basically
it shut down and reset and started again
at any sign of this I was mostly
involved in developing the software for
this parallel system Cristina did most
of the hardware as I recall and
Ranjha develop this FM detector for
electronic cigarette lighters I should
say that I was my day job was still in
the university I was a PhD student and
then research fellow through til 1981 I
only joined the staff in October 81 so I
don't really know what happened to the
to the fruit machine business once we
got something working I don't know if it
led to a longer contract what I do
recall is that concurrent with that
Chris was setting up science at
Cambridge with Clive Sinclair and they'd
decided to try and sell this mk14 a sort
of small microprocessor PCB with a
hexadecimal keypad and 7-segment display
and I know they got the first circuit
for this and I Vera wired a prototype of
that in my front room discovered that in
copying the mass programmed ROM into the
two fusible link roms that were on the
MK 4 team they managed to copy it wrong
so I did a little bit of debugging of
that so I had an early hand in the MK 14
work but Roger looked at the MK 14 and
and did the classic thing of saying I
can do better than that and and he went
home that Easter came back after Easter
with a design for this machine with
again a hexadecimal keypad and a seven
segment display this time based on a
6502 the MK 14 used the SCMP that we'd
used in the fruit machine and the 6502
is a nicer processor to program the SCMP
had a number of curious features and and
thus the circuit was simpler it was
generally more elegant and more powerful
the uses you could put this to work
we're pretty basic I mean you could in
the lab use it to control you could
write software that would wiggle the i/o
pins to control something you could
write little programs do
do simple computations on the display
and so on if you believe the BBC with
Blake 7 you can control the 22nd century
interstellar spaceship with an acorn
system one so it was really an
instrument for learning about micro
processes it found quite a lot of
interest in hobbyists and I think some
university departments also used it for
teaching students the sails I don't know
the sales numbers but I'm guessing that
they were in the thousands maybe 10 20
thousand I'm not sure they required
people who were prepared to do quite a
lot of work to get into them to use them
to do things and I think they even they
were they were sold as kits so they were
restricted to the market of people who
knew which end to pick up a soldering
iron did they have a cross into your day
job did you would you have a tape on
into the lab because obviously you've
mentioned that you were working on were
the things you could potentially use it
for in your day job or did you keep did
your two wheels really separate I never
used a system one in my day job but the
the system one was built on two euro
cards and very soon after that was
released CPU limited under the marketing
name acorn built larger systems which
were based on card frames and these
cards were plugged into a rack and then
you could put a video card in there you
could put an interface to it the
conventional keyboard you could
basically grow it up to something bigger
now I didn't use that directly my
relationship with with the embryonic
acorn was that I was building little
cards myself prototyping them and then
giving the design to acorn who then
commercialized them in particular I
designed an A to D converter so I had a
very similar system at home based in the
card frame which I built myself and I
did use that in my work up to those days
most people who wrote a PhD thesis would
write it by hand on paper and give it to
a secretary to
type up who would laborious ly type it
on two sheets of paper but computers
were just arriving so I wanted to write
my PhD thesis I got to that point so the
first thing I did was I wrote a text
editor for my machine at home which I
built myself and then I wrote my thesis
on that and then I devised a way of
conveying it across through a parallel
cable to one of these computer
automation LSI fours and then we could
take the information to an LSI for with
a daisy wheel printer attached and
because my thesis has some mathematics
in it
I needed a big twin wheel Daisy wheel it
had a Roman wheel and a Greek wheel then
my thesis was printed on about 200 feet
of continuous paper so it came out like
a very large toilet roll and then had
the guillotine is up in two relevant
size units and and bind it yes I also
used the Machine I built at home I think
for gathering some experimental data but
it's the first use was for writing the
thesis my text editor which was cobbled
together very quickly and and was full
of death traps so it had it had a change
buffer and if you over ran the change
buffer by one character it just crashed
and lost everything that was tidied up a
bit by which I mean extensively
rewritten and became acorns edit program
but as I say that there was far more
work that went into transforming what I
had written into the product then I'd
put into the first prototype
16-bit microprocessors could not use the
bandwidth that was available in the
memory that people put in these machines
so you've spent your money you bought
some bandwidth and then you were
coupling this to a processor that
couldn't use that basic resource and
this just struck us as wrong